This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The moment is at hand the countdown reaches zero. In 1957, a few months after the Soviet satellite's Sputnik became the first human object in space, the United States launched Explorer I. Explorer is in orbit, broadcasting to the world its code and scientific data, cosmic ray intensity, meteor impact, solar radiation. These are the dry facts that will help carry a man ever father into the age of sleep. And with that, the space race was underway.
这里是 99% 隐形。我是罗曼·马斯。时刻已经来临，倒计时归零。1957年，在苏联的人造卫星“斯普特尼克”号成为人类第一个进入太空的物体几个月后，美国发射了“探索者一号”。探索者号正在轨道上运行，向世界广播它的代码和科学数据、宇宙射线强度、流星撞击、太阳辐射。这些是枯燥的事实，将有助于把人类更进一步带入太空时代。随着这一切，太空竞赛拉开了帷幕。
And the two world powers began launching more and more satellites every year. A lot of these early missions failed before they ever made it into orbit. That's producer Emmett Fitzgerald. But there were successes, and little by little space started to fill up with human-made objects. By the summer of 1961, there were 115 satellites circling the Earth. And it was during that summer that the US launched an unmanned rocket carrying the Transit 4A satellite. And about two hours after launch. The rocket blew up.
这两个世界大国每年开始发射越来越多的卫星。许多早期任务在进入轨道之前就失败了。制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德说道。但也有成功的，太空渐渐开始充满了人造物体。到1961年夏天，已有115颗卫星在地球周围环绕。正是在那个夏天，美国发射了一枚载有“远距4A”卫星的无人火箭。大约在发射两小时后。火箭爆炸了。
It was the first known object to unintentionally explode in space. And it created about 300 fragments of totally useless space junk. Some of these pieces got pulled into the atmosphere and burned up, but around 200 are still up there today. At the time, most people weren't all that concerned about a few bits of metal floating around in the vastness of space. I think the general feeling was that space was big and that we could put objects, satellites up into space without really having any consequences to that.
这是第一个已知的在太空中非故意爆炸的物体。它产生了大约300个完全无用的太空垃圾碎片。其中一些碎片被拉入大气层并烧毁了，但大约有200个至今仍留在上面。当时，大多数人并不太关心在广袤太空中漂浮的几块金属。我认为普遍的感觉是太空很大，我们可以把物体、卫星发射到太空中，而不会带来任何真正的后果。
This is Hugh Lewis, a space junk expert at the University of South Hampton. Back in the early days of the space age, it wasn't seen as a problem. While the universe may be infinite, orbital space, the region where objects revolve around the Earth is finite, and the amount that we use regularly is even more limited. Most satellites end up in a few particular orbits,
这是休·刘易斯，南安普顿大学的太空垃圾专家。早在太空时代的初期，这并不被视为一个问题。虽然宇宙可能是无限的，但轨道空间——物体绕地球旋转的区域——是有限的，而我们经常使用的数量则更加有限。大多数卫星最终会进入几个特定的轨道，
almost like freeways. And the traffic on those freeways is actually quite a lot, and that's where the problem starts to emerge. As the traffic increases, so does the chance of collision. One of the regions of space that got busy pretty quickly is the area called Low Earth Orbit. That's a region of space that extends up to an altitude of about 2000 kilometers. That's really heavily congested.
几乎就像高速公路一样。这些高速公路上的交通量其实非常大，问题也正是从这里开始出现的。随着交通量的增加，碰撞的几率也在增加。太空里很快变得繁忙的区域之一是被称为低地球轨道的区域。那是延伸到大约2000公里高度的太空区域。那里真的非常拥挤。
And when a satellite stops working in Low Earth Orbit, it can stay in that region for hundreds of years. By the mid-1960s, there were already lots of old and defunct satellites floating around up there. And NASA began to look into this. They started to really think about the potential issues that space debris, orbital debris might pose in the future, and that was an activity that was really led by Don Kessler, who was at NASA at the time. My name is Don Kessler. I started the Arble Debris program at NASA. Kessler is retired now, but when he got started at NASA, he was studying meteoroids.
当一颗卫星在低地球轨道停止工作时，它可以在该区域停留数百年的时间。到20世纪60年代中期，那里已经漂浮着许多陈旧且失效的卫星。美国宇航局开始研究这个问题。他们开始认真思考空间碎片、轨道碎片未来可能带来的潜在问题，这项工作主要由当时在NASA的唐·凯斯勒领导。我叫唐·凯斯勒。我在NASA启动了轨道碎片计划。凯斯勒现在已经退休了，但当他刚进入NASA时，他研究的是流星体。
And specifically, what happens when two meteoroids collide and break apart into smaller pieces? Eventually, Don Kessler started doing similar research on space junk, or as NASA calls it orbital debris. Kessler was studying what happens when one piece collides with another, and this is what he found. Every time you have a breakup, you have increased the probability of another collision, and that eventually just causes the whole population to continue to increase exponentially with time. This idea that space junk multiplies as more and more objects collide and break apart came to be known as the Kessler Syndrome.
具体来说，当两个流星体相撞并碎裂成更小的碎片时会发生什么？最终，唐·凯斯勒开始对太空垃圾进行类似的研究，或者正如NASA所称的轨道碎片。凯斯勒在研究一个碎片与另一个碎片相撞时会发生什么，这就是他的发现。每次发生解体，你就增加了另一次碰撞的概率，这最终会导致整个数量随着时间呈指数级持续增长。这种随着越来越多的物体碰撞和破裂，太空垃圾成倍增加的想法被称为“凯斯勒综合征”。
And Kessler predicted that the growth in space junk would eventually snowball. And that cascading phenomena after a hundred years gets to be well out of control. There's not much you can do about it and you've created an environment that becomes very hazardous to spacecraft. If the growth in SpaceJunk went totally unchecked, Kessler predicted that space could become so filled with debris that it would be difficult to fly a spacecraft without getting hit.
凯斯勒预测，太空垃圾的增长最终会像滚雪球一样越滚越大。这种级联现象在一百年后会变得完全失控。你对此无能为力，你创造了一个对航天器极其危险的环境。如果太空垃圾的增长完全失去控制，凯斯勒预测太空可能会被碎片填满，以至于在不被击中的情况下飞行航天器将变得困难重重。
Kessler's findings were discussed throughout the Space Community, and in 1979, NASA started its Orbital Debris program to study and monitor space junk. And they appointed him to lead it. Around that same time people began to use space more and more. Countries all around the world were launching weather satellites, military satellites, communications satellites, and amateur radio satellites. And because space isn't owned by any one government in particular, low Earth orbit began to experience a tragedy of the commons.
凯斯勒的研究结果在整个航天界引起了讨论，1979年，美国宇航局启动了轨道碎片计划来研究和监测太空垃圾。他们任命他来领导这项工作。大约在同一时期，人们开始越来越多地利用太空。世界各国的政府都在发射气象卫星、军事卫星、通信卫星和业余无线电卫星。由于太空不属于任何特定政府，低地球轨道开始经历“公地悲剧”。
Lots of different countries were leaving trash everywhere, but no one was tidying up. The amount of junk in space continued to grow throughout the 20th century, but it wasn't until 2009, long after Donald Kessler had retired, that people really started to take the issue seriously Two communication satellites have collided in space Around 800 kilometers above Siberia. It's the first car on February 10th 2009 the aridium 33 an active US communication satellite struck a defunct Russian satellite called the Cosmos 2251 it was the first collision between two fully intact satellites and it created thousands of pieces of debris.
许多不同的国家到处留下垃圾，但没有人去清理。太空中的垃圾数量在整个20世纪持续增长，但直到2009年，在唐纳德·凯斯勒退休很久之后，人们才真正开始严肃对待这个问题。两颗通信卫星在太空中相撞。在西伯利亚上方约800公里处。这是2009年2月10日的第一次碰撞，铱星33号（一颗活跃的美国通信卫星）撞击了一颗名为“宇宙2251”的废弃俄罗斯卫星，这是两颗完全完好的卫星之间的第一次碰撞，它产生了数千块碎片。
Donald Kessler wasn't surprised. 40 years prior, he had predicted that the first major collision between whole satellites of this size would happen around the new millennium. For most people, the collision made the problem of space junk feel much more urgent. So I think that the Rydium Cosmos collision really was a wake-up call, and certainly it sparked a new wave of research and funding even for space debris. That's Hugh Lewis again. Lewis says that it's hard to estimate the total amount of space debris out there, but
唐纳德·凯斯勒并不感到惊讶。40年前，他曾预测，这种规模的完整卫星之间的首次重大碰撞将在千禧年前后发生。对于大多数人来说，这次碰撞让太空垃圾的问题变得更加紧迫。所以我认为铱星与宇宙卫星的碰撞确实是一个警钟，它无疑引发了对空间碎片的新一轮研究和资金投入。休·刘易斯再次说道。刘易斯表示，很难估计外面太空垃圾的总量，但
scientists can track anything larger than 10 centimeters in diameter. We're talking about maybe a population of objects that are soft, full size or bigger that is about 30,000 objects in orbit at the moment. Everything from small fragments to old rocket bodies to satellites the size of a bus. And that's just the stuff that's large enough to track. There are potentially millions of millimeter-sized bits of debris, shards of glass, screws, flex of paint.
科学家可以追踪任何直径大于10厘米的物体。我们讨论的可能是一群全尺寸或更大的物体，目前在轨道上有大约30,000个物体。从小的碎片到旧火箭箭体，再到公交车大小的卫星，应有尽有。而这还只是大到可以追踪的东西。潜在的还有数百万毫米大小的碎片、玻璃碎屑、螺丝、漆片。
And even that tiny stuff can cause real problems when it's whipping around the earth at up to 17,000 miles per hour. Yeah, the object does not need to be big in order to carry a lot of energy and to cause a substantial amount of damage if it were to hit anything. The most vulnerable thing in orbital space is the International Space Station, which routinely has to make newvers to avoid collisions with larger pieces of space debris.
甚至那些微小的东西，当它们以高达每小时17,000英里的速度在地球周围鞭笞时，也会造成真正的问题。是的，这个物体不需要很大就能携带大量的能量，并在撞击任何东西时造成相当大的破坏。轨道空间中最脆弱的东西是国际空间站，它必须定期进行机动以避开较大的空间碎片。
The International Space Station is also equipped with expensive heavy-duty shielding to protect it from smaller bits of space junk. Astronaut Tim Peake recently took a picture of a sizeable divot in one of the space station windows where a piece of debris penetrated several centimeters into the glass. So that's the constant reminder for the astronauts on the space station. Every time they look at that window, that's a recognition of the threat that's out there. But it's not just a threat to astronauts. So much of our technology here on Earth is dependent on vulnerable satellites. You know, pretty much everyone in the UK, you know, in the US, probably has a smartphone with GPS capability on it.
国际空间站还配备了昂贵的高强度防护罩，以保护其免受较小的太空垃圾的侵害。宇航员蒂姆·皮克最近拍下了空间站窗户上一个相当大的凹陷的照片，一块碎片穿透玻璃几厘米深。所以这是对空间站宇航员的不断提醒。每次他们看着那窗户，就是对外面威胁的认可。但这不仅是对宇航员的威胁。我们在地球上的许多技术都依赖于脆弱的卫星。你知道，英国和美国的几乎每个人，可能都有一个具备GPS功能的智能手机。
That's a service that's provided by spacecraft. And when you think about navigation signals that are used for aircraft that are flying in the sky, it's everywhere in our daily lives and not just for convenience, it's for our safety. International telephone communication, weather forecasting, keeping track of time in different parts of the world, all of this is dependent on satellites. Global banking systems fall down if we lost the signals we get from space. These risks are causing scientists around the world
那是航天器提供的服务。当你想到用于飞机的导航信号时，它在我们日常生活中无处不在，不仅为了便利，还为了我们的安全。国际电话通信、天气预报、记录世界不同地区的时间，所有这一切都依赖于卫星。如果我们失去从太空获得的信号，全球银行系统就会崩溃。这些风险促使世界各地的科学家
to look into how they can clean up this space environment. Now, when someone wants to put a new satellite into space, there are UN guidelines that say, you have to come up with a plan to dispose of that satellite within 25 years. There are a couple issues with these guidelines, though. One, they're not being followed by everyone. And two, even if they were more closely adhered to, it might not be enough to make space
研究如何清理这个太空环境。现在，当有人想把一颗新的卫星送入太空时，联合国有一些指南，规定你必须提出一个在25年内处理掉这颗卫星的计划。不过，这些指南存在几个问题。第一，并非所有人都在遵守。第二，即使它们被更严格地遵守，可能也不足以使太空
safe. Because there's already so much stuff up there, and as Donald Kessler discovered, space junk multiplies. Even if we stop putting any more stuff up there, the number of pieces of junk will continue to grow. And then we start to think about, okay, how do we address the problem, perhaps a bit more proactively? How do we deal with the stuff that's already up there?
变得安全。因为上面已经有太多东西了，正如唐纳德·凯斯勒所发现的那样，太空垃圾是会成倍增加的。即使我们停止往上面发射任何东西，垃圾的数量仍将继续增长。然后我们开始思考，好吧，我们如何解决这个问题，也许更积极一点？我们如何处理已经在那上面的东西？
All around the world, engineers are dreaming up ways to remove debris from space. In many cases, by sending it down into Earth's atmosphere to burn up. You throw a net over the object, harpoons that have been talked about. There are proposals for space-junks slingshots and solar sales that could carry a piece of junk out of a dangerous orbit. Robotic arms, attaching a really long tether to the object to try and bring it down, attaching a solid rocket motor. No matter how you do it, removing an object from space will be expensive and politically complicated.
世界各地的工程师都在梦想着清除太空中的各种方法。在许多情况下，通过将其送入地球大气层焚烧来解决。你把一张网扔到物体上，人们还讨论过鱼叉。有人提出了太空垃圾弹弓和太阳帆的提议，可以将垃圾从危险的轨道上带走。机械臂，将一条很长的系绳固定在物体上试图将其拉下来，附上固体火箭发动机。无论你如何做到这一点，从太空中移除一个物体都是昂贵且政治复杂的。
But right now, the European Space Agency is planning a mission to remove one of its derelict satellites and they're considering these kinds of ideas. That mission is scheduled to take place in 2023. So we are on the cusp of this type of activity. But even if we found the perfect technology to safely destroy all of the space junk in Earth orbit, not everyone is on board. I completely agree that this is a problem
但现在，欧洲空间局正计划执行一项任务，以清除其一颗废弃的卫星，他们正在考虑这类想法。该任务计划于2023年进行。所以我们正处于这种活动的风口浪尖。但即使我们找到了安全摧毁地球轨道上所有太空垃圾的完美技术，也不是每个人都赞同。我完全同意这是一个问题
we need to do something about. But I think the way that it's framed leaves out a really vital factor and that factor is human cultural heritage. That's Alice Gorman. I'm also known as Dr. Spacejunk. I'm a senior lecturer in the Department of Archaeology at Flanders University, and I do research on space archaeology,
我们需要做点什么。但我认为这种表述的方式遗漏了一个至关重要的因素，这个因素就是人类文化遗产。那是爱丽丝·戈尔曼。我也被称为“太空垃圾博士”。我是弗林德斯大学考古系的资深讲师，我从事太空考古研究，
particularly looking at spacejunk in low earth orbit. For much of her career, Alice Gorman, or Dr. Spacejunk, researched Aboriginal culture in Australia. I'd been a professional archaeologist for many years and I was working on a consulting job in Queensland and looked up at the sky and realized that some of those points of light were not stars or planets. They were actually human manufactured spacecraft, and some of those bits of staff were space junk. And that's kind of what archaeologists do.
特别是研究低地球轨道中的太空垃圾。在她的职业生涯中，爱丽丝·戈尔曼（或太空垃圾博士）大部分时间都在研究澳大利亚的原住民文化。我做过多年的专业考古学家，当时我在昆士兰州做咨询工作，抬头看着天空，意识到那些光点中有些不是星星或行星。它们实际上是人类制造的航天器，其中一些东西就是太空垃圾。这就是考古学家所做的事情。
We're focused on the stuff that people discard, the stuff they throw away, that the garbage of humanity. So while the rest of her colleagues continued digging in the dirt, Gorman turned her attention skyward and began to study the archaeology of space. Because amidst the scraps of floating debris are some really remarkable artifacts. A lot of those things we currently call space chunk are actually quite extraordinary objects that have so much to tell us about the early history of the space age. I've got a lot of favorites in
我们专注于人们丢弃的东西，他们扔掉的东西，人类的垃圾。因此，当她的其他同事继续在泥土中挖掘时，戈尔曼将目光转向了天空，开始研究太空考古学。因为在漂浮的碎片中，有一些非常卓越的文物。我们目前称之为太空垃圾的许多东西实际上是非常非凡的物体，它们向我们讲述了太多关于太空时代早期历史的信息。我在
Loweth Orbit, Vanguard one Vanguard one is definitely one of them. Launched by the United States in 1958, Vanguard one is currently the oldest intact object in space. There's little grapefruit size, aluminium sphere with four antennas sticking out on the sides. It's floating around up there, along with the most recent satellites,
Loweth Orbit，先锋1号。先锋1号绝对是其中之一。美国于1958年发射的先锋1号，目前是太空中最完整的历史最悠久的物体。它是一个几乎有葡萄柚大小的铝制球体，两侧伸出四根天线。它漂浮在那上面，连同最近的卫星一起，
along with technology that's so incredibly different. And there are objects in orbit that look nothing like a traditional satellite, like the West Ford Needles, which were these small copper antennas that were sent in the space in the 1960s. They were really tiny, so they were only like a centimeter big.
以及截然不同的技术。轨道上有一些物体看起来一点也不像传统卫星，比如西福德针，这是20世纪60年代被送入太空的小型铜天线。它们真的很小，大约只有一厘米大。
And the idea was they would form a reflective halo around the earth that radio signals could be bounced from. Using radio waves for global communication never really took off, but some of the needles are still up there, bunched together in little clumps of copper. So I find them really fascinating, and there's probably a lot more of those kinds of stories and objects out there that tell a story of technology that could have gone in one direction, but it veered off in another one instead.
当时的设想是它们会在地球周围形成一个反射光晕，用来反射无线电信号。利用无线电波进行全球通信从未真正流行起来，但其中一些针仍然留在那里，成簇地聚集成一小团铜。所以我发现它们真的很迷人，而且可能还有更多这类故事和物体，它们讲述了技术可能朝一个方向发展，但最终却转向另一个方向的故事。
But Gorman's all-time favorite piece of space junk might be the track satellite, which the US Navy launched from Cape Canaveral in 1961. And it was the first satellite to have a poem in it. Written by a professor of Italian literature at Yale named Thomas Bergen. And one stanza of the poem is inscribed on one of the instrument panels inside the satellite. So it was kind of already conceived as a cultural object. And that cultural object is still up there orbiting the earth about a thousand kilometers up. The poem reads,
但戈尔曼最喜欢的太空垃圾可能是“塔拉克”卫星，美国海军于1961年从卡纳维拉尔角发射了它。它是第一颗包含一首诗的卫星。这首诗由耶鲁大学意大利文学教授托马斯·伯根所写。卫星内部的一个仪表面板上刻有这首诗的一个诗节。所以它从一开始就被构想为一个文化物件。而这个文化物件仍然在地球上空大约一千公里的轨道上运行。这首诗写道：
All of these objects might seem far away and inaccess human love, the chill of space. All of these objects might seem far away and inaccessible, but the day will likely come when we can go and visit them. You can already get to the International Space Station for a cool $20 million, and Gorman says that one day we will be able to fly coach into space. It's quite likely that, you know, when it's accessible and affordable thing to do, people will go into space and maybe start some fancy orbital hotel. And the two things we know from what's happened already that they will want to do is take a lot
所有这些物体可能看起来遥不可及，人类的爱，太空的寒冷。所有这些物体可能看起来遥不可及，但我们能够前去参观的那一天可能会到来。你已经可以花区区2000万美元去国际空间站了，戈尔曼说，总有一天我们将能够坐经济舱进入太空。很有可能，你知道，当这是一个触手可及且负担得起的事情时，人们会去太空，也许还会创办一些高档的轨道酒店。从已经发生的事情中我们知道，他们会想做的两件事是拍摄大量
of photographs and have sex. But, after a while, that stuff's going to become old hat too. And what happens when zero G sex gets boring? Historical space tours. That's what. You might have different kinds of tours. You might say, let's do the amateur satellite tour. Or you might say, let's do the Cold War satellites. Or you might say, let's go and see all of the satellites that come from,
的照片并发生性关系。但是，过了一段时间，这些事情也会变得老套。当零重力性爱变得无趣时会发生什么？历史太空之旅。就是这样。你可能会有不同种类的旅行。你可能会说，我们来个业余卫星之旅吧。或者你可能会说，我们来看看冷战时期的卫星。或者你可能会说，让我们去看看所有来自，
you know, my nation's space agency. So yeah, I totally think this stuff is going to happen. It's going to be one of the things people do once we actually have a space tourism industry that people can afford. But the irony is, in order to have viable space tourism, we need a safe, orbital environment. And so, if we don't find an effective way to clean up some of the junk in space,
你知道的，我国家的太空机构的卫星。所以，是的，我完全认为这会发生。一旦我们真正拥有人们负担得起的太空旅游产业，这将成为人们要做的事情之一。但讽刺的是，为了拥有可行的太空旅游，我们需要一个安全的轨道环境。因此，如果我们找不到有效的方法清理太空中的一些垃圾，
we might never be able to go and see the good stuff. And it's kind of frightening. It's in the most extreme version of this, having ventured out to the moon and with spacecraft, the voyages beyond the solar system, we would actually be shut back on Earth. So Gorman is all for cleaning up space. She just wants us to think carefully before we destroy something that we might want back.
我们可能永远无法去看那些美好的东西。这有点可怕。在最极端的情况下，在冒险前往月球并使用航天器进行太阳系之外的航行之后，我们实际上会被关回地球上。因此，戈尔曼全力支持清理太空。她只是希望我们在摧毁我们可能还想要的东西之前三思而后行。
Because she can imagine the archaeologists and historians of the future trying to wrap their heads around humanity's first trips into space. There will be so many mysteries, so many things that don't make sense. So many stories that you have a little bit here and a little bit there and you're trying to fill in the gaps. And those future archaeologists will thank us for leaving some space junk, right where it is. 99% invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, with three few Seth Sam Greenspan Katie Mingle Kurt Colstead, Avery Truffleman, Delaney Hall,
因为她可以想象未来的考古学家和历史学家试图理解人类的第一次太空之旅。会有这么多的谜团，这么多说不通的事情。会有那么多的故事，这里有一点，那里有一点，而你正试图填补空白。那些未来的考古学家会感谢我们把一些太空垃圾留在原地。《99%隐形》本周由埃mett Fitzgerald制作，还有Seth Sam Greenspan、Katie Mingle、Kurt Colstead、Avery Truffleman、Delaney Hall，
Taren Mazza, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Ok Akumi of Hell Audio for some of the music that we use this week. We are a project of 91.7 KALW San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, all of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible, you must go to 99pi.org. Radio tapio. From P.R.X. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Taren Mazza以及我Roman Mars。特别感谢Hell Audio的Ok Akumi为我们本周使用的一些音乐提供了帮助。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的Radio Row。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目，我们都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解关于这个故事的更多信息，包括酷炫的图片和链接，并收听《99%隐形》的所有剧集，你必须访问99pi.org。Radio tapio，来自P.R.X.此剧集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。